hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
activities that Iran is engaged in in
her short work the virtue of selfishness
and indeed in her larger body of work is
engaging and criticizing and ultimately
rejecting and providing reasons for
rejecting other rival moral theories or
perspectives so what are we talking
about here we're talking about any other
approach in ethics that she considers to
be wrong handed or misguided and in
doing so this is not a particularly
innovative or unusual thing in the field
of ethics you see every major moral
theory and every major moral theorist
doing the same so utilitarians need to
be able to say for example why it is
that other things either amount to
utilitarianism just not done quite so
well or are opposed to utilitarianism
and are thereby wrong for this and this
and this this reason and Rand is doing
something quite similar in terms of her
Objectivist or rational egoist
ethics so in Chapter 1
of the virtue of selfishness the
Objectivist ethics she talks in terms of
three main let's call them families of
theories she actually calls them a each
of them a theory but we should
understand them as more like a bundle or
a bucket that that theories fall into if
they have certain characteristics and
she sketches out a certain sort of very
broad history of the development of
moral ideas this is very early on and
she also makes some rather startling
claims she says that no philosopher has
given a rational objectively
demonstrable scientific answer the
question of why man needs a code of
values so long as that question remained
unanswered no rational scientific
objective code of ethics could be
discovered or defined and then she
brings up Aristotle who she's a big fan
of the greatest of all philosophers
Aristotle did not regard ethics as an
exact science so she's she's claiming
that what she's doing is for the very
first time a truly scientific objective
type of ethics now again that's not a
radically new claim we see people like
Thomas Hobbes making that in Leviathan
and we can set that aside for the moment
but if you accept that point of view
which we're going to do for the time
being then the story that she's telling
makes quite a bit of sense so she says
that most philosophers took the
existence of ethics for granted as the
given as a historical fact they were not
concerned with discovering its
metaphysical cause or objective
validation many of them attempted to
break the traditional monopoly of what
she's calling mysticism in the field of
ethics and allegedly to define a
rational scientific non religious
morality so that's good actually going
to be stage two so what is stage one
it's what she's calling the mystic
approach or a theory or a perspective in
ethics so let's take a look at what she
actually says about that the mystics and
here she's not using the term in a very
precise sense to mean you know what we
we can label as mysticism in say
Neoplatonic philosophy or you know when
we're talking in a religious studies
sense she's using in a very broad
essentially pejorative way of talking
about anybody who's non rational and
appealing to something supernatural or
God or anything along those lines so she
says they held the arbitrary
unaccountable will of God as the
standard of the good and the validation
of their ethics so any sort of ethics
that has a religious basis whether that
be that of you know traditional
Christianity or Islam or Mahayana
Buddhism I mean if you look at people
like to say buddhism is non-theistic
that's not entirely true and and we
could talk about other you know
spiritual leaders is sort of straddling
the line think about the Confucianism
any of those sort of things Rand would
probably place in the bucket of mystical
and she says that a little bit later on
this is towards the end of the the
chapter
she says the mystic theory of ethics is
explicitly based on the premise that the
standard of value of man's ethics is set
beyond the grave so there's some sort of
heavenly reward whether it be a better
reincarnation or paradise or avoiding
Hell or who knows what it's going to be
she says that it's set by the laws or
requirements of another supernatural
dimension and she goes on a little bit
further and you know I think she's
actually getting at something that we
see some religious perspectives putting
forth so she's not entirely distorting
you know the essence of religion and
talking about this but it certainly
doesn't apply to everyone she says it
means that ethics is impossible for
human beings to practice it's unsuited
for and imposed to man's life on earth
that man must take the blame for it and
suffer through the whole of his earthly
existence to atone for the guilt of
being unable to practice the impractical
so it's saying essentially there's this
this whatever it is this transcendent
ideal that's being set up
purportedly the will of the divine and
human beings can't measure up to it but
they're nevertheless supposed to measure
up to it so they feel guilty and that's
what's driving them and it's thoroughly
irrational and she says this is what we
can associate with the Dark Ages and the
Middle Ages they are they are the
existential monument to this theory of
ethics meaning that we can look at those
time periods and their cultures and
their moral discourses and say aha
there's there's the mystical theory of
ethics so put that aside for the moment
and we come to what she calls the social
theory of ethics and she says that this
is derived from philosophers who are
trying to get past any sort of religious
trend you know transcendent supernatural
grounding of ethics and they're trying
to provide something in its place and
she calls them neo mystics because they
replace God with the good of society and
she says collapsing into the circularity
of a definition such as the standard of
the good is that which is good for
society and then she says this means
that society stands above any principle
of ethics because it's the source
standard and criterion of ethics the
good is whatever society wills and this
means that the individual has to be
subordinated and if need be sacrificed
to the demands of society which is
really the demands either of an elite
who's deciding what to do with the
social levers or a sort of vague khun's
exception or a concrete experience of
other people so the social theory of
ethics is saying that the human being
ought to be sacrificed if need be for
the good of others and again she
discusses this at the end of the chapter
here we go
saying that although it claims its chief
concern is life on Earth it's not the
life of man at the life of an individual
but the life of a disembodied entity the
collective which in relation every
individual consists of everybody except
himself as far as the individual is
concerned his ethical duty is to be the
selfless voiceless right list slave of
any need claim or demand asserted by
others so you know this this view is
that one doesn't really have any
intrinsic value or rights except in
relation to the other or the vast
assembly of others a big ol other that
is society then she says philosophers
got to the point where they declared
that reason has failed ethics is outside
the power of reason no rational ethics
can ever be defined and in the field of
ethics and the choice of values of
actions pursuits life goals man must be
guided by something other than reason
and this is you know easy to identify
with what happened in at least
anglo-american philosophy in the early
20th century with the theory of
emotivism right which took great hold
and i suppose you could say well you
know you could sprinkle in there a bit
of cultural relativism as well and sort
of general suspicion about ethics that
turned into this burgeoning discipline
of meta ethics where people were less
concerned about you know working out a
substantive
somatic ethics and more about you know
the nature of ethical language or things
like that you know - engaging in high
order reflection and the result of that
is that a certain kind of erosion takes
place and she calls this the subjective
theory of ethics because everything does
become essentially subjective what can
we use other than reason she gives you a
number of different candidates here
faith instinct intuition revelation
feeling taste urge wish and then she
italicize as this afterwards whim I mean
what could be more subjective than whim
she says today most philosophers agree
that the ultimate standard of ethics is
whim they call it by other names
arbitrary postulate or subjective choice
or emotional commitment and then she
says you know and she's recognizing
something quite quite important here she
says if that's the case then it's not
quite so innocent as we'd like to
pretend the question is whose whim will
dominate who gets to call the shots as
she says the battle is over the question
of whose whim one's own or one society
or the dictator or god whatever else
they may disagree about today's moralist
agree that ethics is a subjective issue
all right so she sees that as a real
problem and you know she's going to say
that strictly speaking it's not a theory
but a negation of ethics and she goes on
to say it's a negation of reality and
negation not only only of man's
existence but all existence and that's
you know quite quite a claim being made
there she's also going to talk about
hedonistic ethics meaning the pursuit of
one's own pleasure but she's
understanding this as being in a
ultimately non rational way
leads to what she calls moral
cannibalism she talks about the moral
cannibalism of all hedonist and altruist
doctrines and she says that it lies in
the premise that the happiness of one
person necessitates the injury of
another the sacrifice either of one's
own pleasures or of another person's and
she talks about this at a number of
different stages there is a kind of
selfishness that is irrational and
misguided from the perspective of random
at one point she actually talks about
Nietzsche as an example of this in in
his moral code saying that you know you
should try to dominate other people and
she proposes something else instead the
moral ideal of the traitor who neither
gives nor accepts what is not you know
earned right she also is going to talk
about and this comes up in the
discussion of Lifeboat ethics in chapter
3 the ethics of emergency she talks
about the false dichotomy of altruism
and we haven't been using this word
altruism all that much but the mystic
theory of emotions the social theory of
ethics the social theory of ethics and
even to some degree the subjective
theory of ethics provided doesn't lapse
and a mere selfishness of a misguided
sort they're all forms of altruism so
what is altruism it's being other
centered making the other more valuable
than oneself making their needs their
wishes their desires the priority and
denying oneself in the process so she
she says that altruism frames things
incorrectly
she says altruism destroys the concept
of any authentic benevolence or goodwill
among people it indoctrinates people
with the idea that's a value another
human being as an act of selflessness
thus implying that you can have no
personal interest in other
that too value another means to
sacrifice oneself and that any love
respect or admiration a person may feel
for others is not and cannot be a source
of their own enjoyment but is a threat
to their existence here's the the the
final word a sacrificial blank check
signed over to his loved ones and she
says look if you accept this dichotomy
you've got two choices one side is to
sacrifice yourself to others the other
is to say wow I'm not going to sacrifice
myself to others I'm gonna make others
sacrifice themselves to me and she does
point out most men do not accept her
practice either side of altruism
viciously false dichotomy but the result
winds up being an intellectual chaos on
the issue of proper human relationships
and the help that one can give to others
so altruism just by being out there
induces this false dichotomy which then
makes it more difficult for us to think
things through in a properly ethical way
so each of these is a moral theory or a
sort of comportment or perspective
within ethics that leads us astray from
rands Objectivist or rational egoist
perspective which she is preferring as
the only genuine ethics available to us
you